Americans financial situation actually
improved during the pandemic she claims
the reality is Jeffrey doesn't agree
with that versus what the public
perception is
I'm not asking you to play therapists
with the American voter but there seems
to be a disconnect between the numbers
we're seeing and the way people are
feeling about the economy and how do you
account for it I I agree with you that
there's a disconnect and
um I don't have a simple and convincing
answer but Americans have been through a
lot the pandemic really took a toll on
American families on children on
households we are enjoying a remarkable
recovery but
um also with high inflation much of it
reflecting Supply bottlenecks that
developed during the pandemic and then
with Russia's brutal attack on Ukraine
we saw a surge in gas prices in food
prices
Americans have been reeling from high
inflation they do realize in polls that
it's coming down and Americans financial
situation actually improved uh during
the pandemic
Drew thank you for that Collective drone
I think I think that was huge Jeffrey
both of you all right the way though
that she combines all of these things
right so and like I was just shocked it
didn't get to climate change also right
like of course that'll be that we
probably cut the clip too early but this
combination of things that sort of have
nothing to do with each other but are
the talking points of the day she did it
very seamlessly there yeah she's very
clever well you know when she refers to
the pandemic was devastated the pandemic
response yes that's exactly my take
that's what we did is what we did in
response to the pandemic that destroyed
everybody the virus didn't call it
caused this and did you catch how she's
blaming Supply chains for the inflation
they never want to talk about the
Federal Reserve you know which which
Unleashed you know helicopter money
worth 6.5 trillion dollars you know
we've never seen at the height it was
something like 27 annualized increase uh
just uh yeah just incredible and as for
Americans doing better yes got stimulus
payments do you know the value of those
stimulus payments is now gone in light
of all the inflation
the dollar is lost between 16 and 20
cents from its 2019 uh uh value and so
the stimulus payments are gone it was
the greatest head fake in the history of
Economics I mean it's like look you're
rich you're rich oh thanks this is
wonderful and and then they just took it
all the way uh through inflation as for
uh the Americans being better off right
now she's completely neglecting a very
interesting survey that comes from the
Census Bureau now I trust this one
because this is where the Census Bureau
is actually asking people how much money
do are you making this year and the the
survey comes out every year it's not
from the BLS it's not from uh an agency
that the Bible Administration has now
gotten clever at controlling it's from
the Census Bureau so I tend to trust it
it comes out once a year it just came
out
American median household income is down
for the third year in a row in real
terms so what she said is absolutely
wrong